- [Isabella] MOMA is
doing her retrospective
as part of a series of
performance-art-focused exhibitions,
and they're trying to create
a history and a lineage
that hasn't really really existed.
I'm really glad that Marina
is so eager to sign on
and pass it onto us and train us.
- [Marina] This workshop
and exercises is a great way
to prepare performance artists.
The idea is cleaning your own body.
We always used to clean the house outdoor,
but indoor house never been cleaned.
(gentle drumming)
It's really interesting
to see how the performance
can be present in a museum life.
There will be reperformance
of five of my performances
by the young performance artists,
who are doing this workshop right now.
- This week has been intense,
difficult, enlightening,
ecstatic, and blissful.
And at times, very frustrating as well.
(metronome ticks)
- [Isabella] Doing exercises
like a three-hour slowness exercise
and sleeping in the same quarters
combined with not speaking
with this group of people,
but being physically very vulnerable
because we were naked in
front of each other sometimes,
and I feel like cemented us as a group
in a way that we couldn't
do with five meetings
where we were talking.
- I didn't quite know what
it would be like to eat gold,
but it was actually delicious. (laughs)
- [Rebecca] I had never eaten gold before.
I wondered, "Could I
possibly be allergic to this
"or how will my body react
after not having eaten
"for a few days?"
- [Marina] It's for me very important
to be part of this workshop
because, I, in my own real
life, I'm not so disciplinated,
but I need a structure and that structure,
it's given by this workshop.
I really like to thank you
for doing this with me,
and it's not been easy.
And there was moments of crisis, I know,
but in the end, you've been wonderful.
You've done everything right.
And incredibly happy and proud.